what's up guys i'm using the audio from
the mic on the camera
i brought
this
the thing that plugs in
from here to the laptop and then
the xlr to the mic so i forgot two
cables
so we're just going to use a mic from
the camera and we're going to talk about
all the new cool things that are
happening right now biden got covered
which is sad because he is our leader
and without him we are adrift at sea
a lot of our
country relies upon biden's leadership
and
energy so
of course without biden
we're gonna suffer horribly
unfortunately
our dear leader has
gotten sick and he's 80 years old
um
but yeah there's a lot going on i'm in
new smyrna beach uh florida which is in
florida
in the americas
and i did a little run you know the
the florida run started out unexpectedly
with the phone call on tuesday
that i was going to go to
uh
dania beach with michael yo opening up
for the great michael yo and i open up a
weekend at the dania beach improv
[Music]
so i was uh
so yeah i was just doing that
so i did a weekend in dania beach
i bombed a lot there just because
they're
like a bunch of upper middle class
uh suburban folk there and it's just i
don't think that they like
playing around with racism and how the
holocaust
they've got their mindset and they don't
really want to hear a new take on
ukraine they just want to be like oh no
this is just
this is just how we're doing ukraine we
can't think about ukraine any other way
so i just think that they were very
rigid people that
weren't really
flexible in their
intellectual
queries
but then i
went back to austin did kill tony did my
dating show and then
then i went back out
into the great realm
of florida and i did
i did naples i did tuesday wednesday at
naples off the hook comedy club met some
great people there hung out after the
show just had a great time
um
you're like 20 minutes away from daytona
why are you at the small beach i mean
how big does the beach have to be i just
need like a couple of
[ __ ]
couple of [ __ ] yards of sand and then
the water i don't really
it's like once a beach is beachy enough
then it's really no different from any
other beach
the difference between a beach that's
amazing and a beach that's
just like normal average beach is pretty
similar to me
unless you like going
um but other than that it's just sort of
like
i'm just there for my own self-care i'm
gonna go in the ocean i'm gonna sit in
the sand and really you don't really
need a lot of space to do that
um so yeah i don't really
understand the appeal of a boutique
beach unless you like to go there and
awkwardly not
talk with strangers
unless you're like really into talking
with strangers that's fun
um
i didn't know andrew schultz was on
jerry i
think that i did see him
uh i think i did see it i did definitely
meet andrew schultz in person at his
studio i was in andrew schultz's studio
when joe rogan was recording that
uh podcast that he did i was in the
green room for that
and it was an adventure it was like a
little play
there were different characters we were
all waiting our asses off it was three
hours we thought it'd be one hour maybe
two and it was three
we're all just sitting there and we're
all going through our own emotional [ __ ]
and it was like a really crazy green
room trip just to be sitting there
and it was it was literally like a play
there was like different characters
uh and i one day if i ever want to win a
tony award or whatever i want to film
that as a play i think that'd be really
funny
because there were so many different
characters and different things going on
um
yeah i mean if beaches suck it's like it
sucks if it's like not sandy enough or
if it's too rocky if there's too much
driftwood then it's not a good beach
um but yeah it was like the bodyguard
there was another comedian
that i probably shouldn't say who he was
was there we were all waiting there was
joe's friend who's like a pool hustler
that was there there was me
i like to think i was a narrator because
i had no other purpose i had no defining
character
experience to be in the green room for
that
um
but yeah so i
so i did the first week in dania beach
with michael yo opening up for him
featuring at the dania improv bond a lot
there just because
the audience there i don't think was
really my style of audience they really
weren't there to uh
they they were sort of a normal
just
upper middle class old people
uh who weren't really that interested in
thinking in new ways or
questioning america's place in the world
um
and then i went back home then i went
out to off the hook in naples florida
and did two shows there that i opened up
for tony hinchcliffe at the improv
in
tampa the tampa improv
and then i went back home
and then i went to
uh tampa again to do side splitters
and then i did
winter haven where there was like 70
tickets sold but 20 of them are like 50
tickets old but 20 of the people didn't
show up they're like we've never had
this many no shows before i don't know
what happened but people didn't show up
but the side splitters in tampa was
pretty much sold out and then last night
a new smyrna beach was pretty much sold
it was definitely sold out so you know
winter haven
kind of [ __ ] up but the people that
were so nice they gave me this gift this
guy nathan
bearden gave me this
this little gift
handcrafted he works for like the mlb or
something and there's a little shoddy
shiny glass in here
so the people that were really nice and
they're really excited for the show but
like some of the people that bought
tickets to show up i don't know what
happened
and then last night was here in new
smyrna beach at mad caps comedy club
which is a really
packed house full of drunk white people
i don't think
like i don't think like 30 percent
they were just
kind of stuck in their ways and
they were just uh you know they're old
and floridian they don't give a [ __ ]
they're too rich and white to care about
what other people think about them
they're just going to act a fool they
have no shame so they were heckling and
they were acting a fool
but i hope i got some good clips i think
i slammed a couple of them so
hopefully i can put that up online
uh but yeah they were like really
offended that i said that the supreme
court was [ __ ] all over women and
they were like how dare you we love the
supreme court here so like politically
you know it was a we were on different
wavelengths
so i think that
that was a contributing factor
um
yeah i mean i wish i was an actor doing
stand-up comedy unfortunately i'm just
doing stand-up comedy you know it's
pretty easy to do there's a low barrier
of entry anyone can do it it's hard to
get an audience to come out for you
and i'm in this lucky spot where an
audience does come out for me so i'm
trying to utilize it and exploit it for
financial gain i have a lot of
merch that i'm probably not going to
sell out of
i wish i didn't order so many but yeah i
got a lot of merch
um
i'm going to put it up online so that
people can buy
until i get home
i get situated but i should be home for
a little bit and then this weekend i'm
going on a little trippy poo
i don't know if i can say where and how
and with who but
let's just say i'm excited for it
and there's also a little sporting event
that i might be at so it should be fun
um
yeah
the snl guy
i don't know what justin all guy you're
talking about but yeah i woke up today
put out my poster put out a post
bragging about how many people showed up
on instagram
then i went to the beach
took a little dip
uh there was like
cars parked on the beach which is crazy
they just drive along the beach here
let me see
display capture
um
okay sure
my mouse disappears
let's scoot this one down
the [ __ ]
okay
yeah i mean
um
yeah there was cars parked on the beach
which i think is unnecessary it's like
you know
it's kind of dangerous to have cars
right next to people just laying around
and it kind of ruins the vibe when
there's giant cars blocking the view and
it's just
polluting and loud and ugly there was
like a golf cart there that had uh the
trump flag
the black the back the blue flag and the
confederate flag that was just trolling
along
yeah it was just like an interesting
trashy environment that i was in
i uh
yeah i mean i i think it's just an
interesting
choice
an interesting uh
display of priorities but yeah this is
the beach
and they're just like
parked along the beach it's like why
don't you just build a parking lot next
to the beach instead of parking on the
beach like it's paved over so much of
the [ __ ] and it's like they have this
giant five lane six lane five lane i
think five lane highway this strode
that's not really a street and not
really a highway
it's just like
it's impossible to walk next to
so you have this wonderful beach and
then right next to it is a giant road
that humans aren't allowed next to so
it's like tempting humans to go
there and then it's making it difficult
once you're there to be a human
but if you made like a nice community
around the beach then you wouldn't need
a park on the beach
it's like this is the only place we
haven't paved over lift quick let's
drive our cars on it it's like why don't
you just create a livable walkable
community right next to the beach so
that you don't have to park on the beach
uh yes
it's just an interesting thing where
like americans they just
love cars so much so they build
everything for cars
if i were offered snl i'd probably take
it
but i'm probably not going to get
offered snl and i don't really know what
the point of snl is
i guess i like making sketches but i
don't really have any practice at it i
want to be good at making sketches for a
while um but it's a great skill to learn
it's great language to learn how to
communicate and so i'd love to get a
crash course
i'm getting a bit lately two shark
attacks in july
and way down south it's
amazing oh yeah to the south padre
island
i've been there
yeah i just uh don't really
like it
right there it's just like everyone's
trying to be tough
and
you know like people who are
uh
white have an advantage
and my ethnicity and my the novelty of
my ethnicity is easily ignored like
whatever
we love white people
and it's like
here in smaller cities
it's like
you have to be something that they
understand they have you have to be like
uh [ __ ] oh you're a douchebag with a
best backwards baseball cap and you
probably love drinking beer and you're
in a frat or you're like an athletic
black dude
and they're they're they're like oh we
understand that character that
stereotype but if you're like somewhere
in the middle and you're like sort of
unclear it's not clear what kind of
character type you are
then people don't immediately know
because these are these are simple folk
they need to understand who you are at a
glance or that they don't have any
empathy for you or are willing to
understand you and try to figure you out
so i think it helps to have like an
immediate look to you
here in in the country and in the
[ __ ] smaller cities
and i don't think that uh
i don't think that i have an immediate
uh
character or look so i don't think i'm
very successful in the sexual
marketplace here
um but yeah also i get in my head and
i'm like oh like do these people want to
talk to me like are they like
small town minded are they going to be
like oh this is who are you who are you
friends with what are you doing here
it's like does everyone know each other
here and it's like they don't really
take kindly to conversing with strangers
like i think talking with strangers is a
skill and i don't think that you get
enough practice if you're out in the
country
and uh yeah it just feels like that
they're it's like easier for them to be
mean to me
i just
am not down to be mean to that
so i just don't like going out here
but that it should be fun if i like
don't give a [ __ ] and i can just go up
to people and be like hey what's up you
[ __ ]
country hicks do you ever see an asian
before and just like talk [ __ ] to them
but
yeah i just think that uh
there's a lot of like
aggression here that's unchecked because
they're not around people
like you are in the city so when they
see a person
they're more likely to fight them
and be aggressive and violent but in the
city if you're aggressive and violent to
people then you're just going to be
exhausted because you're always around
people so there's like in the city
there's more people
a person has not fought
more people
given the opportunity
like the percentage of people that they
fought versus the percentage of people
they could have fought is very low
whereas in the country like they don't
see as many people
and so they don't have as much practice
not fighting with people
um
so yeah i mean i just
don't like the vibes and i also don't
like
i think it's political too i don't think
it was always like this i think people
uh
kind of downloaded the latest political
[ __ ] going on they're like oh we are
hateful and violent and aggressive and
selfish
given what trump is putting out there
let me be more like that that's who i'm
supposed to be
this is american and like back in the
day they were like an american is a good
hard-working man who respects people and
loves nature and is out in the country
but now like they're like i'm an
american i don't give a [ __ ] about
mexicans [ __ ] you
uh i'm gonna make a lot of money and i'm
gonna make you suffer so i just feel
like there's a lot of that
in in small towns which are more
conservatives
uh this [ __ ] ac is leaking
dropping water but yeah it just feels
like um
it's it's like a thing that's been
happening lately where like people are a
little more aggressive out in the
country because that's what they think
that they're supposed to do they're like
oh we're fighting the libs the libs are
nice and soft and [ __ ] let me be the
opposite let me be aggressive and also
like covet put a lot of people
economically deprived so they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] uh they're more stressed
out and more likely to be angry
but yeah yeah
i didn't like going out last night i
don't like the vibes i don't like the
way that people acted
but you know maybe that's just me maybe
i need to go out tonight
and just talk to strangers and just be
vulnerable and open myself up
to this world
that is
mostly good
and just see what happens just
instead of being afraid and being like
oh these are all trump supporters who
are shitty and dumb
maybe i should just be like hey these
are human beings that uh you know they
came out they want to connect
um but yeah like i was walking along the
street and this pickup truck rolls on by
and then the guy right when he gets
right next to me he barks at me really
loudly
and it's just like stuff like that just
you know it's just like oh
you're you're all like this
which isn't true you know like there's a
lot of people that want to connect and
want to
uh you know build communities and learn
about other people and become more
enriched
with socialization
and that guy is probably frustrated
uh and angry and
uh
tense and
in a bad mood or whatever and he's just
like being shitty to people but yeah i
just feel like
it's normal to treat people shitty in
america like there's [ __ ]
black people that aren't you and you can
enslave them and make them work for you
or put them in prison and call the cops
on
and it's just like i i don't feel like
people value people as much
and they just bark at them and just
treat them shitty and just make him a
shitty make the world a shittier place
yeah but that really [ __ ] me up when
that guy barked at me which is
what he was trying to do so i should
counteract that by ignoring
people like that
um
johanns do you ever miss the band
yeah i do miss the van i wish i had the
van here i just like having everything i
own with me like i had a dream
that i had my longboard here and i could
longboard places
i like that aspect of it i like having
the longboard and everything i own with
me
um
but yeah i i think like right now we're
in a space culturally where we're a
little frazzled and there's a lot of
uh
weird energy and i think we can get out
of it if we fix our politics and fix
what we're doing as a country and our
vibes and our culture like we gotta
figure out what
we're about are we about just trying to
make as much money as possible
for our own benefit
but then it's like if you just are into
your own benefit then you should be nice
to other people because people who are
not nice other people are miserable so
if you really want to be the best you
know like feel the best and
[ __ ]
been like
all about yourself and yourselves
uh your emotions and feeling the best
about yourself then you shouldn't really
care about other people at the end of
the day like
that's what everyone says
so
i mean even if you want to be selfish
and [ __ ] you should still care about
other people to some degree
like that's the thing it's like even all
these people that are selfish they're
like i only care about myself and my
family i save all my empathy that i
should have for my community and my
species
for my family so that i have so much
empathy for my family and zero of it for
anyone else
and it's like you don't want to live in
a community that you don't love
you love everyone you see at the grocery
store instead of just your family and
you mean mugging everyone at the grocery
store except your family and then you're
going to treat your family shitty
because your family are just people and
you've practiced being mean to people
that are shaped like people
um
but yeah i mean i think that uh overall
it's like we gotta choose are we gonna
like be nice to each other and try to
give each other healthcare or are we
going to [ __ ] only think about our
selfish prophets
because we all know how that turns out
at the end of the day if you only care
about your prophets then you destroy the
planet
and you ruin everyone else and that
ruins you because we're communal animals
we need a healthy society to be healthy
individuals and we need healthy
individuals to make a healthy society
but if you only focus on creating
awesome healthy
selves
your own selves and you're gonna
have a shitty community environment
um
uh yeah on hiatus if you want to make me
intros and edit videos please let me
know i'll pay you
um
i usually pay 10 bucks per clip
um like the clips that you see on my ig
or my stories the little podcast clips
where i'm just talking to the camera
those i paid the guy 10 bucks for it
um
yeah was i talking about
communities oh yeah like
some people are like never question the
community always work on yourself
but at some point the community is
detrimental to the individuals so when
does that happen when is working on
yourself not good enough and when do you
have to actually work on your community
and how shitty can people make your
community before you're like wait a
minute
if there were proper roads here instead
of giant highways dissecting my city
maybe i could have a more fulfilling
life and be a better individual maybe if
i had more education
you know i'd be a better person
and if if there's uh the whole vibe is
like if the whole culture is just saying
never question your society only work on
your individual self then they can just
detract and
pillage and rape the community for their
own personal benefit
and um
i never work on
creating the community to be a better
place because everyone's just focused on
themselves
like if you create a swimming pool that
everyone can go to then everyone's life
is enhanced by a swimming pool's worth
of melt and then everyone can become
better but if everyone is
not given a swimming pool then nobody
has that swimming pool and we can't
utilize that to make our lives better so
it helps to [ __ ] have things
uh you know that people can
uh use and if you have good communities
you create good individuals there is no
individuals without the community and to
only focus on the individual and not the
community is like the worst way to
create an individual
um i think it's important to
uh create great communities walkable
cities
that foster humanity
you know like if there was a town square
i could go to where i could sit around
and be relaxed and not have cars
running by at 50 miles per hour
right next to me then i would be there
right now
but you know it's just like
if you live in a suburban plot and
there's nothing but houses for 550
or what's a good number 10 square miles
then it's like you're just going to stay
at home and not connect with other
people
so i think suburbs are like kind of
problematic
and they hurt the whole thing
yeah i wish we could create uh walkable
cities in america i mean new york does a
great job but you know they
don't
really keep up the infrastructure their
subways are falling apart
and they have like a really american
approach to
to creating their cities and how much
they fund their cities like if you go to
asia they spend money
on that [ __ ] because this is like asia
this is like korea this is where the
koreans live
it's like going to
you know
asgard and this is like where the thor
people live why would we create a shitty
home oh we gotta wait for the profit
motive to tell us when to improve our
city why don't we just improve our city
when we feel like it whenever we need to
instead of waiting around for
the invisible hand of the free market or
the benevolence of a billionaire for us
to improve our city we can just be like
i think we're gonna fix the subway right
now like everyone pitch in
and have like a like a system where
you use tax money efficiently
yeah i mean it's like kind of [ __ ]
because like taxes
uh are used corruptly but whose fault is
that corporations and billionaires who
bought out our government and use it to
make them themselves richer
like if you hate government then you
really hate
corporations
who uh buy out our government through
lobbying
what do you mean new york subways are
falling apart i mean they're not very
well kept up if you look at the subways
in japan and tokyo compared to new york
new york subways are
dirty
they're very low maintenance they don't
even have cameras in all of them in
japan and i mean in korea they have like
doors
between the uh
tunnel and the platform it just
looks like a nice place like if you go
to a new york city subway it looks like
someone's dirty bathroom it looks like
the bathroom of a dude
who lives in new york that's like it's
all tiles it's groudy it's gross
um
but um yeah i mean
if if you want to fund the
infrastructure and fix it like we can we
can just decide to do that as a city
like okay i've had enough of this these
dirty subways you know like it's
it's like the cheapest cement that they
could find that's like dry erase so you
can wipe the blood off every time a
homeless person
pukes all over it
it's just dirty and the trains don't run
on time it's like the trains run
whenever they [ __ ] feel like it
it's very american that way [ __ ] you
i'll come when i want to
and we'll just take it like that kind of
mentality doesn't work for a public good
uh mr beast is paving the way for that
in his own way i mean i respect that but
i think we
need a more systemic change
we can't just rely on youtube
celebrities to fix our
our cities and our country for us
because youtube celebrities are just
people that live in this country and we
already have
a lot of those
and we can pool our resources together
to be greater than mr beast we just
choose not to do that we choose not to
work together and if we were designed to
work together we can be greater than mr
beast mr beast is great but we can't
just rely on individuals
to do that we got to be working as a
group we need to use all the individuals
instead of just one individual at a time
but yeah
it's great that we help individuals and
stuff
but uh i think overall we need to like
um
really
just come together and
as a group figure it out democracy
you know like i feel like for a place
that
for a place that uh
prides itself in democracy we very
rarely use it we just let billionaires
shape the country where however they
want
and we don't really we don't really uh
use the power of the people to fix our
[ __ ] because we're like yeah freedom and
democracy but not communism we gotta put
limits on
the power we give people
we gotta we gotta have
we gotta have capitalism not communism
so it's like this is there's like a
natural barrier
to working together and
vote on and that's communism it's like
we can't have too much democracy or else
that'll be communism so we have
this idea of freedom but then we use
that freedom to just let billionaires
use their money however they want it's
like just because you have money
doesn't mean that you are going to use
that money for the good
of the country you're going to use it
for the good of yourself which is not
always for the good of the country
because the country is made out of
people who most of them are not rich
billionaires so you're going to make the
world a worse place for a lot of a lot
of americans and if you
if you make the world
a worse place for
most of the people then you're going to
have less cool people in america
and if you have less cool people your
country's going to suffer this country
is people if we don't value people then
we're not going to have a good country
and how do we treat people we treat them
as crop we use them as minimum wage
employees to enrich one billionaire
and
it's great for that one guy but
i think the sum of our parts would be
greater if more people were awesome
instead of one guy being super awesome
like how awesome does elon musk have to
be to make up for all the people that
have been exploited by our system
um but yeah i mean
i think that uh
we we should create a more rich
fulfilling society and we're just used
to seeing people as trash oh that person
is just garbage this person is not
valuable
let's just throw him away and that way
we can value the valuable people more
but i think that we should value
everybody
and i know that sounds like
participation trophy softness and
[ __ ] like that
but um
i think that's the
most efficient way to use humans i think
it's just a better way to
utilize a resource that is humans
is to
foster and develop and encourage them
and not to just throw them away when
they're not being useful or productive
and to
only praise a certain number of them i
think you get a lot more
cool awesome people and awesome things
when you emphasize and help everybody
and not just
a small number of people
but biden got covered you know
i think it was about to happen
eventually covet has not gone away it's
just a thing just lingering in the
background and hopefully it dies
a peaceful death
and it just
peters away
it just
you know
just uh sort of dies
slowly or whatever
but um
i
don't know if
we're in a good place right now i think
kovid really got us angry at each other
and fighting and i think there's like a
certain population that was just like
no i don't believe
what you had to say about covid i'm
going to figure it out on my own and
anything that the group tells me to do
i'm not going to do i'm automatically
going to assume it's wrong and do it my
way and i think that that puts us in a
bad position for the next pandemic
idris says what do you do with someone
that just doesn't want to contribute a
utopia is cheap by everyone doing their
part
i think what you do with people that
don't want to contribute is you set them
up with food and housing and say
good luck
figure it out on your own
um
just don't hurt us
you know we will give you what we need
we'll give you what you need to survive
so don't be angry at us um
and
what more to
contribute like look at the system that
we have now that's actively
predatory
and preying upon the people and so
people still want to contribute to this
system mainly out of survival and fear
well not mainly partly out of fear and
survival but the desire to contribute
and to help the community that you're
part of is innate in humans and it's
very
it's only a sick society that people
don't want to contribute to which is
what we have now like what do we have
why do you want my life why do you want
to use up all my life's energy to work
in a corporation to make a dude richer
like that is the purpose we have for
people and people still want to
contribute to this and people still take
a lot of meaning so if we're
if people are willing to sacrifice their
life and contribute to the system that
is giving them nothing in return
spiritually
then how much better
and how much more will people want to
contribute when we have a society that
is honest with its people and say here
we'll give you what you need to survive
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to survive on this planet
sustainably
and also explore mars so if you want to
be a part of any of that you're welcome
to but you don't have to then people are
going to want to contribute even more
than they already do now which is still
amazing that people want to be doctors
and people want to go to broken
communities that we have and help that
[ __ ] like
people that just don't want to
contribute that's not a very good
feeling
it's a very bad feeling to be ostracized
from the group and to feel like you're
not
uh
contributing because a lot of our
evolution is based on
survival within a group
and it's like if deer can do it if deer
can be in a herd and all contribute and
help each other then humans are way more
advanced than deer and our empathy and
our ability to survive in the community
is way stronger
but right now we have a society that
is actively
trying to trap people into these jobs
that do nothing for you
besides give you a job title and like
you know some status in society but they
don't help you
become a better person
they just help you make flow charts and
powerpoint presentations and send emails
just to make a company more money that
is like
the purpose of um
of a lot of these jobs
is to just like you know improve the
bottom line of some company
and to
piece the stocks uh the stockholders
so i mean
if we have a system like that of course
people aren't going to want to
contribute so we're like oh people don't
want to contribute
so we should make a more predatory
system that forces people to contribute
but i think if you
if you create a system that doesn't
force people to contribute people want
to contribute even more
then a vibrator you're sitting on or
your air conditioning that's my air
conditioning it just turns on like once
every 10 seconds and buzzes is [ __ ]
weird
how long did you live in canada and
texas
i lived in cal california for like three
months
and i lived in texas for about a year
now
capital cap
is a nice solution by idrift
i think what we need is an
equation uh algorithm
that you can plug in and see how much
everyone is making like
how much does a mcdonald employee
actually bring in the company pay him
that much and don't pay him minimum wage
paying what he's actually bringing to
the company and then pay the ceo what
he's actually doing instead of the
maximum amount possible you don't funnel
all the profits into the hands of the
people that own mcdonald's you
distribute it fairly within the company
like if there's a guy that comes up with
a new sauce that does really well you
pay him
fairly for that sauce idea
to incentivize him to create the next
sauce and to reward him for
creating value that has
increased the profits of that company
and brought joy into the world i think
that if you pay people minimum wage
then uh you're just
uh
not
not using money
in the way that it's supposed to be used
it's supposed to be a tool that
accurately reflects reality and right
now is just
abused
and
people are
victimized by money and they're paid the
least amount possible and then people
who have the power to distribute money
pay themselves the most amount possible
and money doesn't flow it isn't a great
communication
tool like it should be like if people at
mcdonald's that flip the burger if you
plug it into the equation and oh it's
they brought in
three dollars for making that burger and
giving it to this person then the
the economy would be a more rich more
fulfilling place where money is used
like a communication tool oh you made me
happy here's some money you know like oh
here's some more money because you
helped us change a flat tire
i think that would be a better world but
right now we don't have a world where
money is used in the way that it's
supposed to be
and where the communication doesn't
happen with money
and instead it's just
it's just used by the people who are
rich to hoard it for themselves and they
just give the minimum amount possible
that we're willing to accept
and that minimum wage changes you know
depending on how
how much people are willing to
uh
how much
people are willing to put up with like a
mcdonald's worker doesn't earn 7.25
an hour they bring in way more value to
the company
and all that value that they bring in is
going to the rich to the ceos to the
executives to the stock holders
instead of giving all that money that
the mcdonald employee is bringing in
which isn't minimum wage it's way more
than minimum wage otherwise that they
would be out of business
um
then uh
then you will have a more rich economy
the economy will be able to communicate
with each other like the mcdonald
employee isn't earning minimum wage he
isn't
only bringing in minimum wage to the
company he's bringing way more than that
the only way companies make money
is
by paying people as little as possible
if you have a company that pays people
accurately then
it's not going to be as beneficial for
them in the short term and they're going
to be
out competed with
but yeah i mean if you want to have a
country that is only interested in its
short-term survival
then um
just
continue to parasitize your people
continue to parasitize your people so
that you can make money off of them
in the short run and then you'll
eventually cave
i think wages you know should be
um
bargained for
like you should you should have an
equation like how much is this person
actually bringing in instead of just
paying the minimum amount possible
like why is that such a
horrible thing like you think that
people that
work at mcdonald's
shouldn't uh
get paid fairly you want them to be
exploited you want them to get the
minimum amount possible instead of like
what they're actually bringing in like
wouldn't it be better if we all
accurately knew how much money we were
actually bringing in
and like
the value of minimum wage and how much
minimum wage you make changes based on
state so are you saying that some some
people
if you're working in say maine
your
flip of a burger is worth twice that of
someone in mississippi with no
i don't wake up
um and it's like
you can't just let
people who own mcdonald's pay people
however you want
you know you can't just
be like okay the people that own
everything
decide how much we get paid and we'll
just take it because they're gonna give
you two cents a day if you let them
that's just their prop that's their
motive they don't want to pay you the
only way that workers can fight against
being paid as little as humanly possible
is by unionizing and using our power as
a collective to bargain with something
behind it otherwise just taking whatever
the ceos give you is not a fair amount
that's being a [ __ ] that's being a
loser that's just laying down and taking
it like to have an accurate
uh
accurate wage
determined for how what you're doing
what you need to do is fight and figure
out what they're willing to give and
what they're willing to take
and unionize and fight the bosses to
find out how much you're actually worth
um but if you
if the government comes in like reagan
did during the air air traffic
controller strike and he's like no you
can't do that you're i'm forcing you to
work and you don't accurately figure out
how much the workers can bargain for
then you don't have an accurate system
and we don't have very high unionization
rates in america so we have a system
that
where one side is has one hand tied
behind their back and they have to fight
the people that own capital and who own
the company and they have to
uh just take it like there is no other
side of the equation anymore it's just
whatever the bosses decide to pay us is
how much we get paid
um
not all jobs create revenue well then
you should be out of business if you
create a job that doesn't create revenue
then why are you hiring people
[Music]
i mean
we should contribute more and we should
have people have better jobs and have
more skills but what kind of education
system do we have do we create
better people do we have like an
education system that creates better
people
like we don't even try to create better
people and then we're like well you
shouldn't be working at mcdonald's well
look at the schools that you have set up
for them their children their babies and
they have no way of succeeding you don't
put them in good schools they're in
chaotic environments you jail up their
dad and then you're like you shouldn't
be working at mcdonald's well you should
create a better society if you want
better people you can't just do zero for
people you can't just fund
infrastructure the minimum amount
possible and then expect people to be
amazing the fact that people are amazing
just goes to show you how amazing people
are and imagine how much awesome how
much more awesome we'd be if we had the
basic tools that we need to survive and
to succeed
they're not forced to work there though
well how are they going to live if they
don't have any money
like just because you're not putting a
gun to their head doesn't mean they're
economically
coerced to work at a shitty job because
that's the only place that they have
uh when was the first time you heard a
crypto worse you surprised by its ups
and downs
what do you mean by leaders i mean rich
people corporations old white men
and the hamptons and mansions
they're the ones that allow this to
happen
america used to have a great
unionization history we are where the
mayday started alabama had great unions
during world war ii
a lot of black people unionize there
um
i think crypto is good i think we're
just trying to use crypto like
how we use every other part of this
economy and we're trying to speculate on
it and shift things around and it's just
like
it's such a waste of energy
like we could be actually creating
something instead of speculating like oh
i think this one's gonna be good oh i
think that one's gonna do good it's like
such a waste of time and money and
energy and it's like i think we should
be more interested in creating value
instead of like using crypto as a ponzi
scheme to trick other people
but yeah i mean other countries have way
higher unionization rates they actually
love each other more and they want each
other to do well
um
you know like in america with slavery we
got used to treating people shitty and
they were like we're gonna make it
harder for poor people to do things and
we heard that and we're like oh you mean
black people yeah that's fine you know
like
it's okay if they suffer because it's
good for them overall i mean look at how
awesome of a country you are so [ __ ] the
poor
um
i think
it's important to
just
have
some sort of
system that
helps people become awesome
especially children
if you have a system where it's not
possible to rise above where you're born
then
it's not a good system and the system
that we have in america is very focused
on preserving the wealth
where it is now
our goal
isn't to create the best [ __ ] all the
time
it's to
help the people that are the richest in
our country preserve that wealth
and you can see it in the numbers you
can see it in our inner cities
and our
education
and
and i think that
if you look at other countries they have
a very high social mobility rate like if
you're born in the bottom
percentile
if you're born in the bottom quarter of
your society the chances that you are
going to be in any of the other
quartiles of your society should be 25
and the less that's true the more you of
an unfair system you had
um and i mean you know
that brings to question the genetic
component like what if some people are
just born
dunces and they just give birth to
dunces
and no matter how much of a good
education you give them they're still
going to be dances
unfortunately right now in america we
don't have a system that has a good
control group for that
so i think the true number of
perpetual duns dunces is very
low
like maybe one percent of people are
just
not gonna make it they're just too
[ __ ] up
but i think for the rest of the 99
percent that could make it
and are stuck in the bottom quartile
with no ability to go up higher
i think
we need to make this more fair system
and we need to do
engage in steps and focus on making this
a fair system for everybody because that
would make this country a better place
if it was a meritocracy if you were born
in the bottom quarter of this country
and you happen to be great at you know
fission
and
splitting atoms then you should be
focused on and you should be your gifts
should be accentuated and raised and
[ __ ] made awesome
but if you're like a rich guy and you
aren't good at anything
then you should
not
stay and have that money and opportunity
that should go to someone who can
actually use it for good
uh
and i
if you create something like that then
the country would uh exponentially
become better like look at how hard
people work and
how willing people are work to work hard
and dedicate their life to something
when we don't have a fair system right
now when we have a system where we're
the 27th in social mobility in the world
uh like people are still willing to work
out now like so
uh now imagine a system where people
know that it's a fair system where we
know that you can move within the
quartiles and the classes of this
country like imagine how much harder
people would work and
it's not a zero-sum game it's not like
there's only a certain number of people
that can
have a nice standard of living we can
give that to a lot of people we can
distribute that in a good way
and if if you have a lot of people who
are dedicating their life to becoming
awesome you're going to have more
awesome [ __ ]
and there's going to be more
you know cool [ __ ] that we can
distribute to more people
but if you have a system that doesn't
treat people fairly then people aren't
going to work hard if like your goal is
to trap people into these dead-end jobs
so that they can't start a revolution or
change the wealth distribution of this
country in a significant way
then people aren't going to work hard
they're not going to create awesome [ __ ]
it's also true that multi-millionaires
families often become broke after three
to four generations who don't
necessarily drive have necessity driving
them leading to hedonism
well i think that some countries are
better at preserving millionaires than
others
and i don't know if
we have a great system for
you know letting
letting millionaires
uh
fairly
uh be judged by the system but i mean if
you look at the royalty
in some ancient countries
then that's some crazy
amount of wealth disparity there
when am i coming to jacksonville i don't
know
you know doing this [ __ ] it really made
me realize how i could be doing this
anywhere i can just rent out a comedy
club or a theater space sell tickets on
my own
market it on my own
and buy my own hotel room and plane
ticket and car rental car
i could do this
independently
and that's what i think i'm going to
start to do
i'm just going to take a risk
i have enough joe rogan money for me to
try this out in different cities
i'm going to make a little run of it
and just see what happens i'm not going
to wait around for
some guy that owns a comedy club to be
like hey you want to come through and do
this here
it's going to be like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
[ __ ] do it
wherever i want
i'm gonna go to the cities that i want
to go to
uh because i can book hotels i can book
flights these these things aren't hard
to do the only thing is that it's like a
risk i have to risk my money because i
might fly to a city buy a hotel room do
all this for nothing
and i'm fine with that honestly like
it's like a free vacation
with the risk you know like that some of
that [ __ ] will happen so yeah that's
what i'm gonna start to do like i'm
gonna start to go around
the whole comedy club system and do it
on my own and if comedy clubs want to
give me a door deal so that i don't
worry about this [ __ ]
then i'm going to do that too
but i can do this all
on my own
i think that's very attractive to me
i don't know how it works with taxes and
all that
i want to do it just through venmo
and cash up
and zell
but
it's really hard to figure out
how it's going to be and
yeah i don't the thing i'm worried about
is taxes they're going to be like oh
you're gonna report this or whatever so
i'm gonna have to figure that out
but yeah i'm just gonna go around to
whatever comedy clubs i want to go to
whatever theater space will have me find
find a good space for it
uh what i would do would like to do is
like go to the independent places
because there's always like an
independent place that people
in the comedy scene go to
um so
yeah i might do that
yeah i ideally i would find out
a common comedian that i trust in the
scene that i want to go to and be like
hey where's like your underground
theater where people
uh comedians hang out
and how much is it to rent i think
most clubs you can rent for 150 bucks
so if i could do that i can just rent
out a place
for 150 play for pay for plane pay for
whatever
you know
it could work out
i just need to find someone that i'd
want to travel with
and someone who can reliably do it
and my schedule is all up in the air
because i'm
you know subservient to my masters you
know i am a padawan a little apprentice
and my bosses you know they have
uh big shows that are very helpful to my
career that i would rather do so it's
kind of hard for me to schedule things
but
i can figure it out
there's a couple weekends that are open
so like it's so crazy with kill tony
like i'm one of the few comedians my age
that can sell
tickets to shows like people want to
come see me because there's just so many
eyeballs on me
so any city i want to go to i can just
look at the theaters and pick a theater
i want to go to pick a city i want to go
to [ __ ] rent it out
totally independent baby don't need
anybody else
an independent businessman
yeah i uh
i think that the
business of comedy clubs is inherently
exploitative exploitative
exploitative
um
yeah it's crazy because some clubs i
make two thousand dollars at and other
clubs i make three hundred dollars at
so
i just need to stop getting [ __ ]
uh but yeah i'm excited to do it on my
own
because that way it's all me there's no
one else
and i like the idea of that
just people giving me money
independently
and
you know selling merch it's all
you know i i don't have to use any banks
i don't have to
you know
make it official i don't want to use any
credit cards it's just all
going to me without any
percentage going to someone else
i just think that's a really
attractive idea to me
just simplicity it's like we have all
this technology so we don't need all
these agents and things
so that's probably what i'm gonna do
thoughts about becoming a comedy store
regular i would love to be at the comedy
store you know the thing is like i've
got all the this uh
cool credits now
from being in austin
um that i could go to la but to become a
comedy store regular i'd have to be a
regular at the comedy store that means
i'd have to live in la
and i just don't like the system in l.a
or new york there's just too many people
there that have been there before and
that have perverted it to become a
system of ass kissing rather than a
system that is actually about comedy
there's just too many people there and
the
art of social climbing and kissing ass
is just too valuable in a system where
there's that many people it's just so
much harder to actually be funny and be
recognized for it
so i think that
overall
overall i think it's uh
a tough thing to do and plus joe rogan
is going to open up this new club
and like people who live in l.a all they
want to do is hang out at the comedy
store anyways so
if i could do that in austin if they
have a club like the comedy store in
austin
uh joe rogan's new club
then it's like
i'm just gonna be hanging out at one
club anyways what's the point of doing
it in la or austin if i can live better
in austin
then it's going to be the same thing as
la
i'm going to be at one place anyways i
might as well be at one place in
austin than in la
um
but uh yeah i think it's uh it's a great
idea
i would love i love the idea of the
comedy store i don't love the idea of la
or new york i just think that it's been
polluted by too many desperate people
who are too desperate to get ahead that
they're willing to kiss ass and
get in positions of power because they
want it more that people that actually
want to get good at comedy and then they
use their positions of power to only
reward those who kiss their ass because
that's the only thing they respect
that's how they got to where they are
they didn't get there by being good at
comedy so they don't respect people who
are good at comedy if you're not good at
kissing ass then they don't respect you
and i think it's just been perverted the
system in new york and la is just too
much about favoritism and just
it's all favoritism it's just so
pointless
it's uh
it's a pointless game to get good at
because if you can't go on stage and do
favoritism
you got stage time by playing favoritism
and now you're
you have no skills that translate to the
stage i'd rather do it the way i did it
all i did was comedy
and then i had some basic social
awareness to not say the n-word
or you know call
some of my mentors
like
a bunch of
jews
and
now i didn't have to waste any energy
and waste any marbles getting good at
some useless skill now all my skill and
all my energy was poured into comedy
and so
i
i got the stage time and the access
through comedy
and then and i didn't have to waste any
of my energy and bleed off speed
uh getting good at you know
talking to people and drinking and
sharing a laugh with them i i just did
it
through the skill of what we're trying
to get good at
which i'm trying to get good at so it's
just more efficient that way
so coming to new smyrna beach
all right well that's my time thank you
guys so much and i hope to see you next
time love you
i hope that you guys live long